what part of that process i'm sure
there's you know because there's so many
steps
that initial idea reaching out to that
one contact that's
going to get you access what's the most
exciting for you and then what's the the
toughest part
um wow that's an interesting question uh
you know you know what's really exciting
is right before we put him out because
you know how good it is
and you know you kind of have a sense
that that people are going to respond to
it
and you've gone through it all and
that's that's really exciting because
once
once it's actually released it's not
yours anymore it's kind of everyone's to
project on it whatever they want and i
love that
so i'm really excited those those few
moments with your baby
you know alone with your child i i
really get excited by that
but um you know i feel like the most
frustrating part is when
is when you have the movie in your head
and you haven't done anything yet
you haven't found a subject you haven't
um
have found a title you know or you do
have a title
and you have ideas of how it should look
and how it should feel and what the tone
is
but you know the process hasn't even
begun that can be a really anxiety
written
uh process for a documentarian because
you kind of get this sense that like the
world is passing you by there's things
going on and we're not out there
capturing it
so it's like this super like oh and
especially you know
with with people out there like like
vice who
who turn these things out with such
persistence
and uh you know they're they're kind of
terrible like it makes it tough because
i i think like
i'm taking on something called cam girls
and it's going to take me a year and a
half to
to really sink my teeth into this and do
it properly and do it justice and get it
out there
vice could do this in a week and a half
and and it kind of that can be
frustrating
and uh that it all happens in that part
of the process where you're really
vulnerable
where you're really vulnerable because
it's just an idea and you're the only
one that really understands it so
that that's the part of the process that
um i'm learning to enjoy more and
getting more in the moment of
but it's the most frustrating part for
sure